seamos honestos la atroz e infame
invasión de ucrania fue toda una
sorpresa para la inmensa mayor parte de
todos los analistas expertos y
periodistas tanto en el campo militar
como en la política internacional y en
cierto modo nosotros no somos una
excepción lo cierto es que una invasión
a gran escala parecía algo impensable
una intervención militar como ésta con
múltiples frentes bombardeo de ciudades
y tropas desplegadas a lo largo y ancho
de toda ucrania no parecía un escenario
factible básicamente porque nadie
esperaba que vladimir putin se pegara un
tiro en el pie como éste
la invasión de ucrania y las
consiguientes sanciones internacionales
han puesto contra las cuerdas a la
economía rusa y la han apartado del
resto del mundo convertirse en el país
agresor por excelencia ha sido una de
las decisiones más absurdas que se
recuerdan en la escena internacional en
ucrania rusia no tenía nada que ganar y
sí mucho que perder y no se trata solo
de las sanciones o de las bajas
militares sufridas la invasión de rusia
también ha cuestionada la otan
fortalecido el eje atlántico y ha
animado a los europeos a gastar más para
reconstruir sus fuerzas armadas
[Música]
la guerra de ucrania ha sido una especie
de viaje atrás en el tiempo de repente
la guerra fría parece haber regresado 27
de febrero del 2022 putin pone las
fuerzas de disuasión nuclear en alerta
máxima en medio de la espiral de
tensiones por ucrania queridos amigos
amigas rusia puede ser un país
empobrecido aislado y tomado por la
corrupción pero sigue siendo una de las
grandes potencias nucleares
de hecho en términos cuantitativos
hablamos ni más ni menos que de la mayor
potencia nuclear de todo el planeta por
eso en este vídeo queremos responder a
unas cuantas preguntas en qué consiste y
cómo opera exactamente la disuasión
nuclear en los planes de moscú en qué
escenario se está previsto por rusia el
uso de armas nucleares podrían llegar a
usarse en los campos de batalla de
ucrania y ojo porque en este vídeo
también os contaremos por qué las armas
nucleares ya no pueden proteger a putin
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tan atrás en el tiempo como en 1949 por
primera vez la unión soviética lograba
hacer explotar una bomba atómica la era
nuclear del bloque comunista había
arrancado desde entonces una de las
mayores obsesiones de los gerifaltes
soviéticos fue aumentar más y más y más
su arsenal nuclear para que os hagáis
una idea se calcula que los soviéticos
acumularon cerca de 45 mil ojivas
nucleares justo antes de que el imperio
soviético colapsara
hola
[Música]
inicialmente la doctrina nuclear de la
unión de repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas perseguía dos objetivos al
mismo tiempo la meta política y la meta
militar bajo la perspectiva política el
arsenal nuclear de la urss tenía la
misión de multiplicar la influencia
internacional de este país al fin y al
cabo ningún otro estado era capaz de
mirar a eeuu de tú a tú por otra parte
bajo la perspectiva militar la idea de
los soviéticos era lograr que su régimen
prevaleciera en caso de que se produjera
una guerra que eventualmente pudiera
derivar en un ataque nuclear
norteamericano de esta forma los
soviéticos estaban convencidos de que
tener más armas nucleares que los
norteamericanos les daría la victoria
final en un conflicto a gran escala
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas llegaron a tal
extremo que en la década de los 60 por
primera vez las dos potencias
reconocieron el término mar la
destrucción mutua asegurada por sus
siglas en inglés y con ella la victoria
dejó de ser un objetivo y le cedió el
testigo a la disuasión porque amigos
ningún bloque podría ganar nunca una
guerra semejante
precisamente por eso apenas unos años
más tarde las dos potencias firmaron su
primer acuerdo para limitar la capacidad
de las armas estratégicas y los misiles
balísticos pero eso es pasado el caso es
que hace ya más de 30 años que la unión
soviética dejó de existir y fue la
actual federación rusa quien por acuerdo
de todas las partes terminó quedándose
con todas las armas nucleares del
imperio soviético y aunque desde
entonces el terrorífico arsenal nuclear
ha ido menguando el oso ruso aún dispone
de aproximadamente 6 mil 400 cabezas
nucleares si tenemos en cuenta las
cabezas que actualmente están
desplegadas las que están en reserva y
las que están en vías de ser
próximamente desmanteladas una cantidad
repito 6 mil 400 ojivas nucleares que si
bien estaba muy lejos del pico histórico
alcanzado unión soviética- hacen de
rusia la mayor potencia nuclear del
planeta por número de cabezas fijaos
así que teniendo esto en cuenta la
primera pregunta que seguro seguro
muchos nos estamos haciendo es qué
planes tiene rusia para estas armas cómo
y en qué supuestos tiene previsto
utilizarlas pues bien atentos
[Música]
ambición nuclear rusa
por muchos tiranos que hay al frente del
timón hasta en las guerras suele haber
normas sobre todo cuando hablamos de un
arsenal tan destructivo como las armas
nucleares y evidentemente rusia no es
una excepción
la doctrina militar es el conjunto de
principios que determinan los supuestos
y los tipos de acciones militares que
ordenan las acciones de un ejército en
función de cuáles ya las circunstancias
pues bien la última doctrina militar
rusa data del año 2014 pero en junio del
2020 el gobierno ruso aprobó un nuevo
documento titulado sobre los principios
básicos de la política estatal de la
federación rusa sobre disuasión nuclear
con este documento se actualizaron las
amenazas y circunstancias bajo las que
rusia se podría llegar a plantear
utilizar armas nucleares
y la pregunta es cuando dice esta
doctrina que rusia podría usar su enorme
aterrador y aniquilador arsenal de
bombas atómicas está amigos es la
pregunta
en principio o moscú considera que las
armas nucleares son exclusivamente un
medio de disuasión pero claro la clave
está en saber qué demonios significa
exactamente el término de disuasión en
la rusia de vladimir putin pues bien
primero según la doctrina en vigor rusia
lanzaría un ataque nuclear en respuesta
a otro ataque nuclear u otros tipos de
armas de destrucción masiva que se
utilizarán contra rusia o contra algunos
de sus aliados luego en segundo lugar
también podrían recurrir a ellas si
tuvieran datos y de dignos del inminente
lanzamiento de misiles balísticos contra
rusia o sus aliados o como respuesta al
ataque con armas convencionales de
lugares críticos del gobierno o del
ejército ruso y en tercer y último lugar
muy importante la doctrina rusa también
establece el uso de armas nucleares en
caso de que un conflicto convencional
pudiera poner en peligro la existencia
del propio estado
en estos casos la preferencia siempre
pasaría por emplear las armas nucleares
contra objetivos militares grandes como
aeropuertos o grandes bases navales que
asegurarán una gran destrucción en las
filas enemigas con un solo golpe bien
estos son los casos en los que la
federación rusa contempla utilizar sus
cabezas nucleares pero claro llegados
hasta aquí la pregunta que muchos muchos
de vosotros os estaréis haciendo es a
ver enrique todo esto que me estás
contando pues es totalmente subjetivo
qué pasaría si la otan defender a
ucrania o intervenir a militarmente
emilio rusia podría putin llegar a
utilizar alguna de estas armas si la
guerra le va mal pues amigos en
principio todos damos por hecho que las
armas nucleares existen para no ser
utilizadas pero lo cierto es que ya se
han utilizado y que si algo ha
demostrado ser vladimir putin es de todo
menos predecible
[Música]
al presidente ruso le gusta jugar fuerte
de hecho una de las primeras cosas que
hizo putin nada más llegar al poder fue
aprobar una nueva doctrina militar que
amplió los escenarios en los que rusia
podría llegar a utilizar sus armas
nucleares por ejemplo incorporó como
caso posible el escenario de una guerra
regional en lugar del supuesto de guerra
global que estaba en vigor anteriormente
también y esto es muy importante se
incluyó la posibilidad de usar las armas
nucleares en primer lugar y no solo como
respuesta a un ataque enemigo
incluso los servicios de inteligencia y
análisis militar de occidente apuntan a
que el alto mando ruso podría llegar a
plantearse el uso de estas armas para
desescalar una guerra convencional
contra la otan que rusia pues estuviera
perdiendo eso es lo que se conoce como
la estrategia de escalar para des
escalar atacó primero destruyó y luego
ya negocios y el bando contrario pues no
quiere caer en la destrucción mutua esto
es algo no obstante que los rusos niegan
tajantemente una comunidad de expertos
hace tiempo que insistía en que se
publicara este documento a fin de que no
se nos acusará de mantener doctrinas
imaginadas por los americanos como por
ejemplo la de escalation form escalation
es decir pretender utilizar armas
nucleares para alcanzar la victoria en
un conflicto convencional víctor scene
es jefe del estado mayor y vice
comandante en jefe de las fuerzas rusas
de misiles estratégicos en cualquier
caso lo que sí es cierto es que a medida
que rusia se ha ido quedando económica y
tecnológicamente atrás el protagonismo y
el peso de la disuasión nuclear ha ido
cobrando otra vez más protagonismo en la
estrategia de seguridad del kremlin
[Música]
al fin y al cabo a efectos prácticos es
mucho menos costoso tener al día las
armas nucleares y los dispositivos de
lanzamiento que contar con enormes
dotaciones de equipos militares como
grandes flotas navales o grandes grupos
aéreos creo que con la invasión de
ucrania todos nos hemos podido hacer una
idea de las enormes carencias que tiene
el ejército ruso aquí no creo que haga
falta ni siquiera aportar nada en otras
palabras si no fuera por las armas
nucleares o sea ni siquiera sería
considerada a día de hoy una
superpotencia por eso para moscú y
particularmente para vladimir putin
resulta fundamental que el poder nuclear
esté muy pero que muy presente en su
discurso político y esto esto es
precisamente lo que explica en noticias
como la que veíamos antes la recordáis
el 27 de febrero de 2022 putin pone las
fuerzas de disuasión nuclear en alerta
máxima en medio de la espiral de
tensiones por ucrania o también noticias
como esta otra rusia lanza misiles
hipersónicos en ejercicios nucleares
para demostrar fuerza durante tensiones
con ucrania a ver no es que el
presidente ruso esté pensando en
lanzarse a la destrucción masiva sino
que sabe que este es realmente su único
fuerte para intentar ganar influencia
internacional y como tal hay que
entender este tipo de discursos
en principio la doctrina militar en
vigor en rusia no permite el uso de
armas nucleares ni siquiera si se
produjera un enfrentamiento de guerra
convencional en ucrania entre el
ejército ruso y tropas de la otan claro
que mejor no probar suerte de hecho lo
que más miedo genera no es en sí mismo
el arsenal nuclear de rusia sino la
falta de mesura y prudencia que una y
otra y otra vez ha demostrado su líder
pero bien ahora que ya sabemos cuando
rusia podría llegar a utilizar sus armas
nucleares y porque de una forma u otra
éstas suelen tener tanto protagonismo en
el discurso político ruso la pregunta es
qué capacidades nucleares tiene
exactamente rusia pues bien veamos
[Música]
destrucción mutua asegurada
tres palabras tan grandilocuentes como
terribles que marcaron la guerra fría y
que ahora putin parece empeñado en
traernos de vuelta destrucción masiva
asegurada con todos los arsenales
nucleares de las dos grandes potencias
han sufrido muchos cambios y muchos
recortes en las últimas décadas en buena
medida gracias a los acuerdos alcanzados
precisamente entre rusia y eeuu el
último otros acuerdos por ejemplo es el
new start fue firmado en el año 2010
entre la administración de barack obama
y la de dimitri medvediev este acuerdo
amigos tenía que haber expirado en
febrero de 2021 pero dos días antes de
que concluyera by the end y putin
acordaron prorrogar law in extremis
cinco años más hasta por lo menos
febrero del 2026 ahora bien porque esto
es importante y en qué consiste
exactamente este acuerdo pues bien
básicamente newstar limita el número de
armas nucleares estratégicas que pueden
tener cada país a un máximo de 1.550 con
700 sistemas balísticos entre tierra mar
y aire
[Música]
las fuerzas estratégicas rusas con
capacidad nuclear se componen de misiles
balísticos intercontinentales 10
submarinos con capacidad de lanzamiento
nuclear de las clases delta tayfun ivory
y entre 60 y 70 aviones bombarderos
pesados en la actualidad se cree que
rusia tiene unos 310 misiles
intercontinentales repartidos en 11
bases distribuidas a lo largo y ancho de
todo el territorio ruso estos misiles la
mayor parte del tipo mrw son capaces de
transportar hasta mil 189 ojivas
nucleares aunque sólo hay unas 800
desplegadas para su uso actualmente
rusia se encuentra en pleno proceso de
modernización de sus armas estratégicas
y se espera que para este 2022 podría
haber sustituido ya todos sus misiles de
la edad soviética
[Música]
además también se cree que podrían tener
en servicio los primeros misiles avant
gran que es el primer sistema balístico
ruso de hipersónico capaz en teoría de
evadir los escudos antimisiles
convencionales esta tecnología que
también está desarrollando eeuu parece
el futuro de la disuasión nuclear y por
eso países como corea del norte pues
también están intentando lanzarse a la
carrera
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sea como sea el caso es que en diciembre
del 2020 útil dijo que para principios
del 2022 en torno al 88 por ciento de
sus fuerzas nucleares estratégicas
estarían modernizadas bueno ya hemos
llegado esa fecha se supone que es así
claro que también hemos soportado años y
años de propaganda sobre la intensa
modernización del ejército ruso que
luego a la hora de la verdad pues ha
demostrado un poquito exagerada al final
amigos los recursos son los que son y en
rusia pues qué queréis que os diga la
abundancia económica no es precisamente
una característica nacional sea como sea
es evidente que las más de seis mil
cabezas nucleares que aún mantiene rusia
son el gran escudo con el que cuenta
putin es seguro que le permite apostar
fuerte en política exterior manteniendo
el control de daños al menos
militarmente porque parece que a la
guerra económica y el aislamiento
internacional el líder ruso pues nunca
le ha prestado mucha atención visto lo
visto tras la invasión de ucrania craso
error pero llegados a este punto hay una
última pregunta que tenemos que
responder realmente hacen falta tantas y
tantas cabezas nucleares para garantizar
la disuasión pues lo cierto es que no
según una investigación de eeuu 100
cabezas nucleares serían suficientes
para que un país es seguras e incluso en
el peor de los escenarios la disuasión
nuclear por cierto en este mismo estudio
pilotado por un profesor de la
universidad tecnológica de michigan
concluye que sería suficiente en
términos de disuasión establecer un
máximo de 900 cabezas nucleares entre
los nueve estados que hoy cuentan con
esta tecnología militar 900 sabéis
cuántas cabezas hay actualmente en el
mundo pues aproximadamente unas 15 mil
para un tratamiento tico pero el riesgo
queridos amigos amigas putin siempre ha
visto las armas nucleares como el escudo
de rusia sin embargo la crisis de
ucrania ha demostrado que eso fue un
error en un pasado vídeo os contamos
como los aliados occidentales están
tratando de dañar erosionar o incluso
destruir la capacidad económica de rusia
y ante semejante ataque que puede
terminar llevándose por delante al
propio régimen de putin las armas
nucleares son
completamente inútiles putin nos ha
querido devolver a los oscuros tiempos
de la guerra fría pero qué queréis que
os diga los tiempos han cambiado y por
eso en esta ocasión y tal y como ocurrió
en chernóbil con el famoso botón aceta 5
las armas nucleares ya no le pueden
proteger una vez más los horrores de
moscú en ucrania pueden terminar
llevándose por delante al régimen el
poder desgraciadamente también una vez
más los ucranianos sufrirán las
consecuencias como nadie pero dicho esto
turno para ti crees que putin sería
capaz de utilizar armas atómicas como
respuesta a una intervención de la otan
en una invasión rusa a un país como
ucrania déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te
resultó interesante no olvides darle a
like y suscribirte a visual político una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]